and now onto our panel joining me now is
Jason Smith chairman of the Ways and
Means Committee who conducted the first
interview with these whistleblowers and
Congressman Byron Donalds of the
oversight committee who was in today's
hearing Congressman Donald as Jonathan
Turley noted earlier today I think the
most damning moment of the entire
proceeding may have been courtesy of it
was like an unintentional goal by the
Democrat defense and it came from
Congressman Goldman of the Trump
impeachment Fame Joe Biden has
repeatedly denied and it's completely
not credible that he just he never
discussed his son's business dealings
with him but watch this Exchange
Hunter told his dad according to Rob
Walker quote I may be trying to start a
company or try to do something with
these guys that doesn't sound much like
Joe Biden was involved in whatever
Hunter Biden was doing with the cefc but
what it does show that he said he told
his father he was trying to do business
oh Congressman Donald so um the pompous
Goldman just dragged the president of
the United States into this that was
sworn testimony by The Whistleblower now
on the record
uh listen I totally agree with you that
did occur and it was multiple instances
in this hearing one of the things that
came out is that the famous WhatsApp
message that everybody talks about now
were Hunters sitting next to his dad and
he wants more money and you better give
it to us or we're gonna remember and
we're gonna stop everything you're doing
that text message the investigators at
the IRS wanted to get location data to
actually show that Hunter Biden was
where we all believe he was which was at
the Rehoboth Beach house with Joe Biden
the ausa did not allow them to get the
location data this is simple
investigator stuff and Laura look I'm
not an attorney I'm a finance guy but
this is simple common sense if you're
trying to track down the flow of money
and really see how deep your
investigation goes you simply get the
location data the the doj stops the
investigators from doing that and so
there's more information that came out
of this hearing than that not only did
Joe Biden know what was going on but
that Joe Biden in part was benefiting
from what was going on
and Congressman Smith look at one point
I think it was Goldman said well yeah he
might have been there but there's no
sense that he was involved in the
business like he might have been sitting
next to him but I mean it was so
pathetic and they didn't even really I
don't think try because they couldn't
truly impeach the witnesses at all but
there was another key moment from this
hearing that really struck us at the
angle watch
the transition team is a political
operation set up to help the
president-elect vet cabinet employees
work on Inauguration they have any
special investigative Powers I don't
know about
not that I would know of in your entire
history and uh working and history with
the IRS you ever worked with a
transition team of Resident helped set
up an interview with a subject of a
criminal investigation I have not do you
ever get to interview Hunter Biden
we did not
Congressman Smith why is the transition
team the political team of the president
involved in you know trying to prevent
what was obviously the normal course of
this investigation they shouldn't be you
look at the numerous examples that both
of these whistleblowers laid out they
gave countless examples where the
Department of Justice Biden's Department
of Justice delayed delayed a lot of the
investigations they divulged a lot of
information like the to the transition
team to Hunter Biden's lawyers before
they were going to issue a search
warrant in the northern Virginia storage
unit and then there's numerous examples
where they denied prosecution what's
interesting these people always tried to
bring up is the fact that you know
the tax years of
2014-2015 2016 is when by when Joe Biden
was vice president and they're like well
why wasn't there charges brought by
Trump they were still getting together
in the information but the statute of
limitations ran under President Biden
for the tax years of 2014 and 15 which
were some of the most horrendous crimes
according to the investigators we have
the Chinese Bank was sending millions of
energy Bank was sending millions of
dollars and Congressman Donald's um
Ziegler The Whistleblower who revealed
himself today was describing the
intimidation that not just he but other
agents experienced in this investigation
there was an environment when we were
interviewing people when we were
interviewing Witnesses were you were
afraid to ask questions questions that
could lead to the presidential campaign
and this is after the campaign's over so
questions like that it was restricted
and I was it so things like that were we
were limited to talking about
Congressman Donald's
how do Democrats with a straight face
deny that this is a problem with the
facts that are laid out
well look Laura let me tell you first
what Mr Ziegler said there is the facts
those are the facts it's all through his
written testimony
um and in the depositions he took with
the with the Ways and Means Committee
but let me go further in the hearing
today the Democrats didn't even bother
going at The credibility of Mr Ziegler
and Mr shapely because they knew that
would be utterly ridiculous all they
wanted to do was focus on Donald Trump
that's all they did to this hearing and
it was disgusting no talk about the
money that Hunter Biden Jim Biden and
Joe Biden were taken from foreign
countries they didn't acknowledge the
fact that there was a international pay
for play scheme that was going on with
the Biden family they only want to focus
on Donald Trump and I think it's also
indicative of what's going on with Jack
Smith and Mary Garland right now that
it's just funny that these two
whistleblowers come forward today and
all of a sudden there's a new indictment
with Donald Trump going on there are
serious problems at the Department of
Justice and it's going to take House
Republicans to get to the bottom of it
well there was one moment um Congressman
Smith where Jamie Raskin was trying to
argue that Hunter Biden
actually received this was I was howling
when I watched this actually received
tougher treatment
from the IRS I think we have the sound
bite let's watch
the fact that Hunter Biden faced a
four-year criminal probe involving
dozens of agents and prosecutors from
the IRS the FBI the U.S attorney's
Office in Delaware doj tax demonstrates
to my mind at the very least that he
received no special treatment but
arguably selectively tougher treatment
than the millions of the people who
never face criminal investigation for
doing the same thing
these are millions and millions of
dollars in in payments that were
documented today
and how how in this in this universe
would that not be something that our IRS
would want to understand and track if
any normal American without the last
name Biden had beaten the government out
of more than a million dollars in taxes
that they owed they would serve jail
time and in fact
um Mr shapley during the hearing today
highlighted exhibit two that he provided
to the Waze and Means Committee which
was uh which was an exhibit of what they
should bring charges against Hunter
Biden and it outlined several felonies
several misdemeanors all the way from
tax years 2014 to 2019 but to all the
charges that should have been brought
all the charges and even Leslie Wolf the
assistant prosecutor was lined that she
agreed with these charges but guess what
he wasn't charged with one felony his
plea agreement is two misdemeanors where
he slapped on the wrist won't be so
Urban gel time but an average American
would be serving gel time but it's
unfortunate this Administration is truly
truly treating the wealthy and those
politically connected to Biden much
differently than the average American
somebody stepped in here somebody
stepped in here and said this is going
to kill Biden this is going to literally
destroy his presidential campaign or his
political future and that's what we're
going to try to find out we've asked for
several people to come before us they're
trying to stall it but let me tell you
we're not going to stop all right
Congressman both of you thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else